[Music]
our human newborn Auggie Nelson's
current abilities are somewhat limited
you can cry sleep eat and hiccup the
turtle also newly hatched can crawl
separate from her siblings and begin a
vast transatlantic migration alone
without parents or learning her brain
has already formed every connection
she'll need for the great journey ahead
seven months later Auggie is learning to
sit up in a year or so he'll be walking
another decade he'll be walking to
school by himself by that time the
turtle will have completed a solo 9,000
miles circumnavigation of the Sargasso
Sea and returned to the shores where she
was born to build her own nest the
turtle's brain was designed to
masterfully navigate the ocean but
Auggie's human brain was designed to
adapt to any environment play any
instrument calculate the existence of a
spacetime singularity navigate the
Atlantic by himself if he wants
everything he needs to learn these
things is already there we're born with
as many neurons and as many connections
as you're going to need they can go from
any spot of the brain to every spot with
as many connections as possible
and that's a brilliant design by mother
nature because it gives us this
incredible amount of possibilities for
the future but there's a catch that gift
of possibility doesn't last forever like
childhood itself it comes to an end for
each skill we get a golden period when
learning is easy periods in development
we have a heightened plasticity for
shaping neural circuitry and we refer to
those as critical periods learning to
play the guitar as a child is like
opening a door and as a child we have
lots and lots of doors during this time
our neural circuitry gets fine-tuned our
brain learns about which connections are
going to be important through a use it
or lose it principle certain connections
become reinforced and and sustained and
enhance at the cost of others those
connections that aren't being activated
because they're learned not to be
necessary get pruned away they actually
die off and the open doors begin to
close it's an adult if you've never
played you've lost that door so right
now Auggie can learn to speak any human
language perfectly about saying without
an accent when he's an adult he will
have lost that ability if he doesn't
begin learning the violin before he's
about seven years old he'll probably
never play Carnegie Hall if you never
had the connections to begin with you
can try as hard as you can you're never
going to get there play but what if we
could change that play what if we could
tweak our brains to learn as easily as a
child
it's called the holy grail of
neuroscience and it is tantalizingly
close we can to some degree do the
impossible and reopen critical periods
is where allow changes to happen later
on in ways that we didn't anticipate
would be possible scientists are
learning how we learn and that may soon
give us a chance to reopen those doors
[Music]
what actually is neuroplasticity so
neuroplasticity is the ability of the
brain to adapt to changing circumstances
to when the environment changed the
ability of our brain to in a nutshell
learn but there's another side of the
coin just as we need to be able to learn
and adapt we also need stability the
opposite of plasticity neuroplasticity
is brain stability and so in fact that
balance is what we're going to focus on
a lot tonight our first participant was
the first woman to chair the Department
of Neurobiology at Harvard Medical
School
today she's professor of biology and
neurobiology at Stanford University
please welcome one of the world's
foremost neuroscientists Carla Schatz
next participant is associate professor
of psychology at Columbia University
director of the developmental affective
neuroscience laboratory
please welcome NIMH tottenham and our
third participant this evening is
professor of neurology at Harvard
Medical School an MD PhD he says his
research falls in the area between the
brain and the mind
please welcome Alvaro Pasquale leo
so welcome those ready so Karla let's
start with the brain itself we're gonna
be talking about learning plasticity how
the brain learns how skills become habit
but what do these things actually look
like in the brain structurally we saw
already some nice photographs in the
introduction if you remember these black
things and structurally the brain is
composed of neurons and support cells
and the neurons communicate with each
other through electrical signaling
chemical electrical signaling and the
most important aspect of that is that
these communications are transferred
across structures known as synapses and
that's where learning happens that's
where memories are stored and as we were
talking about in in the video that's
where the pruning this pruning process
goes on this use it or lose it process
goes on during development so the in
fact the structure of the brain is just
the brain is packed with these neurons
packed with these synapses and also with
very long connections and some of those
you can actually see in in this
beautiful graphic that's being displayed
now so the brain connections link
various parts of the structure to each
other and those are the beautiful colors
that look like use and so on these
pathways but those are made up of
hundreds and thousands of connections
from individual neurons and their I used
to joke they're more neurons in the
brain than stars in the universe but in
fact an astronomer corrected me and so
that wasn't true
so when you look at an amazing picture
like that we're looking really at the
axons the wiring the wires so is the
brain fundamentally unwired at the start
so the brain is not fundamentally
unwired it's at the start but it is
amazing if you just take the visual
system for example the eye is not
connected to the brain to start with and
the nerve cells in the eye have to grow
their connections along pathways and
select the right part of the brain
namely the visual part of the brain not
the auditory part of the brain or you
know the motor part of the brain so the
wiring from the very beginning is very
highly organized and the formation of
these long tracks or pathways is
dictated by very strict cues like
pathways with or even like roads with
street signs on them so that the these
growing connections are the growing
axons follow these pathways but then the
amazing thing is once the connections
form between these long distant regions
of the brain then there's this period of
overproduction and pruning that we're
going to talk about a period of
extensive plasticity where the outcome
is really predicted by the use of the
circuit itself and the experience itself
so there's both directed kind of
hardwiring early followed by this
remodeling plasticity that happens later
and really persists to some extent
throughout life so building on that if
we think about it if you're building a
house you're not gonna lay copper wires
all over the place and then pull out the
ones that don't seem like they're
working well but that seems to be what
we're talking about it seems pretty
inefficient and the brain is 2% of the
body weight but yet gets 20% of the
blood flow and 25% of the glucose so why
is the brain doing it that way
so on face value there's so much about
brain development that seems inefficient
but actually it's that seemingly
inefficient path that actually gives
rise to the incredible complexity of the
brain especially in the case of the
human so when we're developing what our
brain does is first goes through this
period of over producing our neurons and
synapses and then through experience
through learning what's important in the
environment what synapses are getting
activated those get to stay and
everything else gets sniped away because
it's inefficient to keep all of those
synapses so why would we go through this
entire process of overproducing and then
pulling back that's really at the core
of what the function of childhood is in
the human so if you think about humans
as a species we're amazing in many ways
we can live anywhere on the planet we
can speak any language we can eat a
number of foods and so on and live very
well and some of the reason why we can
do that is because of this long period
of brain development that we have so the
brain overproduces it's like throwing a
big fishing net out into the ocean
because you're not sure which house
you're gonna end up in you're not sure
what language people are gonna be
speaking to you so you're ready you've
got all your bases covered and then
depending on what signals are coming
into the brain the brain learns okay I'm
going to keep these synapses but I'm
gonna get rid of these so if I'm growing
up in a Japanese speaking household I'm
gonna hang on to the synapses that
helped me understand Japanese but get
rid of the synapses that support other
languages because that's really
efficient so it really is this
developmental period a really long one
in humans that gives rise to our
incredible adaptation to our particular
environments so Alvaro is this this is a
new concept we all think everything's
been figured out in neuroscience in the
last 20 years but this need to balance
stability and plasticity tell us a
little more about that about the history
of that conceptually
I think there's lots of new developments
but many of the ideas are not
fundamentally new we have the tools to
actually test the the concepts but you
know the first person to speak about
plasticity and stability as a term and
applied to behavior the human behavior
was was Williams James the psychologist
William James in the 1890s he wrote
about him plasticity as being that
property of the substance of an organ
they presumably of the brain that
enabled us as humans to do certain
behaviors and become really good at it
he was talking about behaviors a habit
not about the brain structure and and he
said you know there amazing thing it it
has a property of giving it to influence
but not giving in all at once you want
to have some plasticity but not too much
plasticity you want the right kind of
plasticity the right amount of
plasticity and and presumably was
romanika Halden not not much longer who
started to look into where does that
actually happen in the brain and and
describe the synapses and and the
changes in the connectivity and the
change of how efficacious those
connections were and making new ones as
the substrate for that plus the cedar
William James was talking about so the
ideas are you know hundred years old and
yet when I was studying medicine I was
told you know things don't change in the
brain and and when you get old world
tough you know and I hope we can do
something about it because I I hope to
get there one day and and I think we
started all no we've always known as an
old dog you can still learn new tricks
and and so it it was against the
experience of everybody that it is
possible to learn new stuff so how does
that how does that gel
together in great so let's go back to
this we were talking about this concept
of a critical period we all know the old
adage that children learn language a lot
more easily than adults but what are
some of the other examples of critical
periods that you see in your work with
children so for a while people were
thinking that there is a critical period
of human brain development that was a
language that people used and then it
became clear that critical periods are
really a property of a developing neural
circuit and so if that's true then maybe
it's appropriate to think of each neural
circuit that we have as undergoing its
own critical period that moment the
metaphor that people often use for a
critical period is that it's a window of
opportunity opening up when the
environment can really have its biggest
impact on the nature of future
functioning for that system so what if
it's true that every neural circuit has
its own critical period then maybe we
can sort of map out the timing across
the brain and so in general what people
find is that the brain develops in this
kind of backward C shaped nature where
regions of the brain that are low and
back tend to develop earlier and then
the development kind of curls around in
waves and so what you often see sensory
systems develop earlier experience
they're critical periods followed by
motor systems and language systems and
finally more of these higher cognitive
functions that particularly in the human
we spend so much time thinking about so
things like our emotion processing or
our cognition academic performance and
so on so that hierarchical structure
really makes sense when you think about
what the needs of the developing infant
child or adolescent are going to be so
in the video we saw a baby turtle that
really doesn't have a childhood it jumps
in the ocean and takes off whereas
humans we have this extended childhood
period where all this has to happen and
you could argue that because we have the
most
to go through experientially that we
have the longest childhood I think it's
another good example of what seems like
an inefficient design right so if we're
gonna stay immature for that long then
we need somebody around us who's willing
to put in the investment to stick around
with us that long so if you look at this
immature period in the human it's really
a long time right in most species this
period of immaturity is on the order of
weeks maybe months and in humans it's
years and so that's a curious design for
mother nature to come up with because
it's a huge energy suck for a parent
right to raise another human being I
don't remember I don't know what the
numbers are but someone computed how
many calories it would take to raise
another human being and it's enormous
so there's got to be a really big payoff
and one of the arguments is that the
payoff is that this affords us as a
species this incredibly long period of
plasticity so that we can do all of the
learning that's necessary to become a
very complex adult so at the same time I
think what we're learning is that that
this notion of development and then you
get to some level of maturity which I'm
still hoping for but but and then you
have a you have a plateau and at some
point things go wrong and you're lucky
you you start losing it that this way of
thinking about it is probably the wrong
way to think about it that instead we
should think of us sort of developing
our entire lifespan until we sort of die
and and that that therefore plasticity
even though it may be through different
mechanisms and different efficacies and
and working on different substrates but
but it's still there it's still there
throughout their lifespan and so it's
not a critical period in the sense that
plasticity is done and now you can
reactivate plasticity you can open
opportunities but but the capacity of
change
balancing the stability is there for the
entire lifespan which is from a
neurologists point of view neurosurgical
perspective a huge opportunity and
reason for hope of interventions this
about this balance between stability and
plasticity is really interesting if you
just think about some of the systems
that that have to form then the you
don't want necessarily plasticity
throughout life in a system let's say
like our visual system where we need to
have a stable representation of the
world inside our brain and then we can
draw upon that to make computations to
put together and to have perceptions and
so on so it's really quite interesting
so some systems really need to go
through this learning period but then to
become more stable than other systems so
let's let's build on a little Carla
because the visual system your mentors
at Harvard Hubel and Wiesel won the
Nobel Prize in 1981 for their
fundamental work on really the first
insights into all this concept in the
visual system so help us understand that
a little more oh sure so this is David
Hubel and Torsten Diesel and my mother
they I used to call them Huebel and visa
land my mother thought it was a person
one person Hubel and Wiesel till she met
them but yeah so so these two these two
wonderful scientists explored the visual
system and began to try to understand
how it is well here's the question how
come we see with one view of the world
even though we have two eyes so both
eyes have complete bring come it's like
you have two cameras I mean both eyes
bring complete images of the world to
the brain yet unless there's pathology
we only see one view of the world and
one the answer to this is both in the
wiring of the connections and also the
fact that the brain has to learn how to
use both eyes together and it does that
during a developmental critical period
so the
connections from the two eyes begin to
be mixed together as the connections
move from the periphery from the retina
itself into the central nervous system
and the first binocular cells are
actually built in at the back of your
brain in your occipital cortex that's
your primary visual cortex but even
though the connections know to grow to
the visual part of the brain they
actually don't know how to tune up to
make binocular neurons and one way they
do that is to interdigitate the
connections between the right eye and
the left eye into a series of beautiful
right eye left eye right eye left eye
stripes and you'll see two images here
actually so there's an image where
they're white and black stripes and
those stripes are equal in size on the
left on the left and then there's
another image on the right where there
are little teeny black holes in the
middle of a sea of white now what you're
looking at let's just say on the left
every little white dot is the size of
about a synapse so one of these
connections and you're looking then at
literally millions of these connections
what you notice is that they're
beautifully organized in these stripes
and when Hubel and Wiesel first
discovered this inter mixing of the two
inputs which are essential for making
the binocular neurons everybody thought
they were hardwired but they did a very
important experiment and the
experimental result is on the right let
me tell you about it in just one other
context which is really to talk about
them the mystery of the cataract so you
know perfectly well if as an adult you
have normal vision your whole life and
you get a cataract as an adult and you
lose the vision in your eye because
there's a clouding of the lens then a
miracle can happen and that you go to
the surgeon and he replaces he replaces
the lens with the clear lens and you see
beautifully again immediately and this
replacement could happen after maybe 10
years of not being able to see well
through your eye now in contrast
a little child who might be born with a
congenital cataract or have some other
problem with vision and one eye if that
cataract is not corrected immediately
then that child will be permanently
blind or have severe vision loss in that
eye so what's the difference ma you know
grandma had a cataract ten years worth
corrected good vision and then the child
maybe has a cataract just for a year
maybe even maybe even happier and it's
corrected the optics of the eye are
corrected the camera works but the brain
can't see so what's the difference so
Hubel and Wiesel did an experiment where
they actually checked the connections
between the eye and the brain that was
shown in the in the right hand side the
open eye the white eyes connections take
over way more than their fair share of
cortical circuitry for vision and the
closed eye has those little piddly you
know black holes and this was an amazing
demonstration a very important
demonstration in fact the first that of
the use it or lose it concept in the
brain that the brain connections require
use in order to be maintained and in
fact even require use in order to be
formed so can you go into a little bit
how you've been building on that work
and I think you've got a video for us of
how the brain does this in real time
this really illustrates a developmental
critical period that happens after birth
but actually we were quite interested in
knowing whether their earlier
developmental critical periods in the
visual system and what we discovered is
that even in before babies are born they
the eye is sending signals to the brain
to start to really shape up these
beautiful stripes and these connections
in the central pathways and the signals
are the electrical signals that are
being sent from the neurons and the
retina into the central part of the
brain and they're actually like test
patterns the
testing the connections and the ones
that are appropriate are being
maintained and the other ones are being
pruned away so this is the same theme
and the video that you see now is a
picture of that signaling process in the
eye so you can just imagine it's like
phone calls being placed to the brain
really early in development and every
little black dot here in this video is
again about the size now of a nerve cell
not a synapse so it's a bigger scale but
you can see that whenever so when when
the cells become black it means they're
placing the phone calls and they're
sending their signals to the brain so
what you're seeing here is neighborhoods
of nerve cells all placing phone calls
together and this is actually part of
another principle of development cells
that fire together wire together so this
is a way that that the eye can sort of
test to make sure the connections are
orderly in the target structure this is
happening so the brain is really
jump-starting vision even before vision
as possible because it's in utero and
it's before the rods and the cones have
appeared and now that we know that this
happens in the visual system it's been
found that this kind of jump-starting
and testing is happening all over the
brain during development very early
development you've been studying ways to
potentially reopen the visual system so
tell us about that a little bit yes so
the well the question is really if these
windows closed can you open them up at
any time and really to try to understand
how to do that it's important to know
something about the molecular mechanism
so what are the molecules that are
opening and closing these developmental
critical periods and in really in
particular what are the what are the
molecular mechanisms that that control
the pruning process itself this
selection process which synapses should
we keep how does the brain know that
certain synapses have been used and they
should be strengthened and other
synapses have not been used so much so
we don't need them so we can actually
prune them away
and so we can use animal models to begin
to discover those molecules for pruning
and in doing that in fact we found a
number of candidate molecules that we
wanted to test to see if they were
important for this pruning process and
so we engineered genetically mice that
lack these molecules to see what would
happen to their critical periods and to
pruning and to our great surprise and
delight what we discovered is that if
certain of these molecules when they're
not their permit the persistence of the
developmental critical period in the
visual system and in fact pruning fails
to happen and so this is illustrating
two points one is that it is possible to
continue you know to extend a critical
period for a longer period of time and
it also indicates the the idea that
there that that brain plasticity itself
can be regulated in a very deliberate
way and if we only knew you know the
whole story about the molecular
mechanisms we really could make pills
and I could take a pill as an adult and
learn French without an accent
so that brings up an interesting point
because Alvaro is over there smiling and
shaking his head that so has a clinical
neurology taking the pills exactly would
you want to take it right away so as a
clinical neurologist and you think about
that and we talk about the balance
between stability and plasticity and as
you're taking care of patients with
strokes and things like that what do you
think about and then what do you think
about in kids as well because
everybody's obviously going to say oh
well you know we got to get these into
humans we got to figure out ways to
extend these windows for kids and for
diseased adults so let's talk a little
bit about the pros and cons of that yes
so I think it's a really important topic
and and and and it is a double-edged
sword right so to have a great efficient
plastic brain that is able to get us to
the
French or English without an accent it
may be very appealing but at the same
time to have too much plasticity can
come with a cost if you have not any
genetically engineered mouse but EDC's
were by design because of the pathology
the brain is too plastic is learning too
fast that seems at face value a great
thing right you're able to acquire
skills that go above the average one of
us you can open up a box of of matches
have them fall on the ground and say 27
and be right or 225 you can learn a
whole book of names and phone numbers
and we call those savant abilities and
and it's sort of cool and certainly a
party joke but but but it comes at a
cost because what happens to the brain
is that normally it yields to influence
to the environmental change and then we
stop and then we experience a new thing
and that new thing falls onto fertile
grounds ready to learn did anything but
it doesn't get colored but what we just
learned the risk of having too much
plasticity is that the brain is change
and then they change falls onto the
change and a change unto the change of
the change it's a sort of a messy noisy
system and we think that for example
diseases like autism are characterized
by excessive too good a plasticity that
leads to a failure of pruning and to do
a developmental disorder because of
another malady in plasticity so to have
too much may be a bad thing so you've
been studying that in autism
specifically to try to look at
plasticity in the autistic brain versus
in the neurotypical non autistic brain
so so what do you find how do you how do
you go about teaching that apart and
what do you find so you have to come up
with with experiments as it were to show
that people with autism can be better at
for example than individuals that are
not autistic things like learning a
sequence of finger movements that repeat
themselves and you need by doing it to
figure out the pattern underneath the
finger movements individuals with autism
learn to do that faster than those
without autism but if you have one
pattern followed by another then they
break down because they run into
interactions between the two things that
they are learning and at the same time
we want to look in the brain and see
what is changing in the brain to allow
them to learn these skills faster and
and we do that in a in a sort of similar
way that that we learn to do it in in
animal models or in in slices of the
brain using electric stimuli to evoke a
response and then using trains of little
stimuli to modify those connections and
see for how long they remain modified we
use that using a technique called
transcranial magnetic stimulation so
tell us a little more about that
technique and how you're able to use it
non invasively to test something like
this to perturb the brain transiently
it's a bit like science fiction still to
me so you you basically put a coil of
copper wire over the subjects head then
as the current passes through the copper
wire coil it induces a current that goes
to the skin in the skull and induces a
current in the brain maybe we can we can
show it and there's a little explanation
that goes with it
qiyamah stands for transcranial magnetic
stimulation it is a way of inducing
current in the brain in a specific
control part of the brain without having
to open up the skin in the scalp and it
turns out that when you apply repetitive
stimuli then you're activating a circuit
over and over in a controlled pattern
and that changes that circuit and so
that allows us to activate probe disrupt
or suppress activity in different parts
of the brain depending on where we
target and what parameters of
stimulation we apply so you can probe
the brain with this technique see the
response apply a little train to modify
it and then what you find in people with
autism is that that the effect of that
modification lasts literally longer than
it does in neurotypical subjects in
those without autism sonam we've talked
mostly now we've talked about about
vision we've talked about motor system
you know you study a lot more aspects of
emotional phases of development so let's
talk about how you've been studying that
in these exact same context of
plasticity and stability so a lot of our
questions are related to the point I
made earlier that we have this design of
spending a lot of time with our parents
while we're growing up and so we have
been very interested in the role of the
parents during this putative sensitive
period for emotional behaviors and so we
know from you know since the time of
Freud there there is this very strong
association between early caregiving
experiences and emotional behavior later
on in adulthood but we don't really know
at the level of human brain development
why that enduring link exists and part
of the answer may have to do with some
of these critical period timing
and the influence of the parents so
we've been asking questions about you
know actually what what good is a parent
right we know that parents are important
but what are they actually doing on a
moment-to-moment basis you know as I'm
rushing my kids out the door to school
shoving breakfast into their mouths to
get them out the door what are what are
those kind of momentary episodes
important for but we also have the
opportunity to ask questions about
children who experience more forms of
adversity early in life and the reason
that we've been very interested in this
group of children is because this early
adversity exposure is one of the number
one preventable risk factors for
emotional difficulties later on in life
and we're just at the beginning stages
of understanding why early adversity in
particular is so important maybe more
important than later adversity and part
of the answer is related to the concept
of critical periods that we're talking
about so you brought up the idea of a
double-edged sword before and I think
that there are many double-edged swords
when it comes to brain plasticity and
another one of those is that brain
plasticity is not really good or bad it
just is right it just opens you up to
the environment and so when considering
or evaluating brain plasticity it's also
important to look at what's the nature
of the environment that the individual
is experiencing when the brain when that
window of opportunity is really open and
so for children that have experienced
significant adversity like caregiving
adversity or what we often call
psychosocial trauma what we have seen
well two main things one is that there's
incredible individual differences in
outcome so some children show some
really significant challenges and others
are thriving so this is an individual
differences story that we really aren't
very good at explaining right now but
the other piece that we've been seeing
this is true not only in humans but
across a number of species is that early
adversity may actually be affecting
brain development on average by
affecting the timing of these critical
periods so there may actually be an
acceleration of the timing or the
opening of these critical periods so if
we know that that's really important to
know in terms of intervention and
prevention because if the timing of
these critical periods is shifting as a
function of early experience then that
informs how we want to treat individuals
and what if new experiences we want to
give to individuals as a function of
these early experiences and that's why
you like to refer to these as you said
before as sensitive periods more than
critical periods for for the processes
that we're interested in these emotional
behaviors and cognitive behaviors that
seems to make more sense to me because
they do seem to be more malleable and in
fact that's why talk therapy is supposed
to work right is that talk therapy is
about teaching the brain something new
about interpersonal relationships and
the reason the only way that talk
therapy can work is if there's continued
plasticity in some of these systems so
we talked a little bit about autism
let's talk a little bit about
schizophrenia because they're another
very complex condition and there are
questions about whether or not
schizophrenia may have aspects of a
disorder of stability and plasticity so
Carla maybe you could enlighten us on
that a little bit well I mean one main
point to make about schizophrenia is
that it's now really commonly considered
to be a developmental disorder
even though often symptoms appear late
in late adolescence or even beyond the
the current idea is that there is this
extended developmental critical period
and
this period is exist beyond the visual
system as an infant's mentioned and
therefore these these systems that are
maturing much later including those that
have to do with interactions and with
cognition and frontal lobe behavior all
mature later so then the question is
what are the changes that have happened
in the brain and again it's commonly now
thought that the that this relationship
really between plasticity and stability
must be perturbed in some way and when
people look into the brain and not a
huge amount has been done but there is
consensus that there are changes in
pruning in the brains of schizophrenic
patients who have donated their brains
for studies so that we can actually look
at those brains and in human genetic
studies so looking for susceptibility
genes that might produce schizophrenia
in children the some of the new gene
candidates that have been identified are
known in animal models where we study
how those genes actually work are known
to regulate pruning in the animal like
the mouse developmental critical period
so you know now you're beginning to hear
a kind of common theme that's emerging
as we talk that there are these critical
periods that involve a beautiful balance
between plasticity and stability
involved pruning and may have different
outcomes not only through our own
experiences but also when the balance
somehow is disrupted by some kind of
pathological conditions so we've talked
a lot about aspects of this balance
let's talk a little bit about how do we
harness recovery of damage after injury
you talked a little bit about about a
traumatic situation but what about
critical
in childhood when we get to adulthood
how do we how do we how do we attack
that problem well I think the way we're
talking about plasticity really is a
huge reason for hope right it suggests
the fact that our brain can be guided in
the in the and the challenge is to learn
exactly that how to guide it what do we
need to do to suppress changes that are
these SS or that could cause problems
and to enhance others that that can
benefit the subject and and and we have
lots of interesting indications that
that is possible to do ultimately that's
what physical therapy or occupational
therapy what speech therapy promotes is
talk therapies guide the changes for the
benefit of the of the subject but I
think we have now as we understand more
of the molecular basis and the
physiologic basis of these mechanisms we
have ways to target this new mechanisms
with medications or with devices with
brain stimulation that more directly to
the brain promote the changes and and
and that's that's happening and and it's
happening guided by basic research and
translating that basic research to
humans so it's yeah I one of the things
that I'm really excited about in terms
of intervention is thinking about how
can we boost the power of current
interventions by knowledge about
critical periods and plasticity so if we
can increase plasticity prior to some
known effective intervention that's
really powerful and so you know as you
mentioned there are many examples in
basic neuroscience where pharmacologic
or genetic administration or
modification can actually increase
plasticity and in many ways bring the
brain back to that childlike state to
allow for some environments have a
really big effect on the
brain that's really powerful and there's
a demonstration in humans too that has
actually used one of these pharmacologic
manipulations with people who don't have
perfect pitch and perfect pitch depends
on a critical period learning early in
development so perfect pitch was able to
be developed in adults who had taken
this pharmacologic drug so then the
question is well why don't we all do
that right and you know the authors of
the study make a really they're very
careful to say that hey remember the
brain actually spends a lot of energy to
prevent these critical periods from
opening up again right the brain wants
efficiency the brain wants reliability
and do we want to remove all of the
lessons that we've learned throughout
our entire developmental history do we
want to remove aspects of our
personality and so on so it's it becomes
a very tricky question even though
there's a lot of promise for recovery
following any type of trauma but in that
perfect pitch study they didn't the the
people didn't lose I mean they learned
right something new so there's there's
hope really there's hope for having
selectively you know in a selective
intervention so that I think that's
exciting I mean from the animal studies
so from looking again at the at the mice
and and actually one of the authors of
that study also has done work looking at
the mouse critical periods for vision as
has my own lab and what we find is that
you can actually go into the adult mouse
brain and really restore juvenile like
plasticity in the adult brain and the
mech
of doing that seems to be again to allow
for new synaptic connections to form and
if we study the the story of the
childhood cataract but now in the mouse
then remember I told you that if
children have a cataract and it's not
immediately operated and clear optics
restored then they become either
permanently blind or seriously vision is
seriously diminished in that eye and
really it there isn't a good way of
treating that blindness is called
amblyopia in adulthood but in these mice
one can actually and make the the
cataract model and then go in in the
adult mouse and engaging these childhood
mechanisms of plasticity again affect
recovery of vision in the eye that was
blind which is amazing and it's really
demonstrates I think that by
understanding the underlying mechanisms
that regulate these developmental
critical periods it's possible to go in
and then to manipulate them again it's
and to me it demonstrates another thing
which is that there must be in in the
adult brain and presumably in our brains
too because we have the many of the same
molecules that are being studied in the
animal models there there must be brakes
on plasticity because these
manipulations essentially take the
brakes off and then of course you can
worry about stability so then we come
back to that this whole theme again but
the idea that there's actually more
plasticity in our adult brain that we
can tap into to me is really exciting
because you could say that even if
there's some downsides that after a
stroke or damage to the brain wouldn't
it be wonderful if it were possible then
to tap into that latent extra plasticity
even briefly and combine it with
training and physical therapy
so somehow a pill that would let me
speak French without an accent could
actually have a really important
therapeutic value which would be to
really help people recovery from brain
damage what we have here is a video of a
modern rehabilitation technique with a
split treadmill maybe Oliver you can
tell us about the concept behind this
yes so part of what physical therapy
interventions like this or like
something called constraint therapy that
some of you may have heard about in
individuals that have stroke that cannot
use both legs in walking correctly or
can reduce one hand correctly if we've
come to learn that if you force the use
of the other hand of the impaired hand
by limiting the default of of just using
the unimpaired hand or but in this case
of the video if you force the walk
incorrectly by aligning the paretic leg
because it cannot cross over and and so
therefore limit the pattern of
abnormality that normally would happen
that because of this repeated training
doing the right thing that that promotes
the rewiring that promotes the plastic
change and speeds up the recovery so you
can by guiding by constraining the
behavior use that as a way to improve
the recovery process and so the
opportunity of opening up the mechanisms
of plasticity in such a way that they
become more active and therefore benefit
from the intervention more becomes
really appealing and and in examples of
that to exist even in humans you know
not only with with medications one of
the things that we know about
Alzheimer's dementia Alzheimer's disease
is that the before the clumps of this
abnormal protein come together and
deposit plaques in the in the brain if
they are floating around and in that
stage already they alter and
Synopsys so they become damaging
substances for the mechanisms of
plasticity as it were if you take
patients with Alzheimer's disease and
you try to get them to learn from video
games or computer games and get better
at cognitive tasks they derive very
little benefit it would take too long to
get a benefit that is sort of meaningful
but if you activate that circuit with
brain stimulation for example just
before they actually engage in the
cognitive training now you get more
benefit from the cognitive training so
so combining interventions divide space
or pharmacologic interventions with
behavioral interventions I think it is
really a a way to leverage what we know
about the mechanisms of plasticity in a
way that translates into benefit for
patients so we've talked a lot about
aspects of disease and repair what about
this holy grail idea what about the idea
of actually enhancing the brain whether
one day I was thinking today you know I
had a long day and I was thinking oh my
gosh I got to focus on what we're doing
tonight and I jump in a car and when's
the helmet going to come out through the
ceiling or already didn't built into the
roof where I could say you know if I can
just get my temporal lobes going and my
memory working a little better like how
great that would be like how far off are
we how far off are we from everyday
enhancement of function
it didn't work so I mean what gave me
pause is that of course there is a lot
of industry investment and and and
really direct to consumer devices
already claiming that that's possible
that we don't need to wait at all that
you can just do it today and you can
build having you can build your own
brain stimulator devices and build it
into your car if you want to and and and
people will will claim and and try to
convince us that that it is possible to
enhance capacities the problem with a
lot of those data is that what they show
is that it's possible to get better
performing a given task not to actually
get better at the fundamental skill that
underlies the task so so I think that
the attempt to get us there is is
already here but but we need to create
our understanding including greater
understanding of that double-edged
aspect that the name was mentioning if
we get better one thing will it be
without a cost or will the brain know I
allow you to improve something at the
cost of something else so for example if
you can you can ask a question and say
what if we were able to get better at
paying attention to this part of the
world we know a lot of what the
circuitry is that allows us to pay
attention to this particular spot and
and so you can actually identify those
brain areas in humans apply simulation
that increases activity in those brain
areas and you can make people get better
attending to this part of the world but
when you do that it comes at the cost of
attending to this part of the world in
fact it does so because this two area
sort of are almost as if they
the yin-yang kind of relationship and so
there are interactions between the two
hemispheres and so if you improve one
you worsen the other and that's easy to
test in something as concrete as spatial
attention for a visual task in something
as complexes as overall behavior or or
more higher order cognitive functions
what exactly the cost might be is much
much harder to test and so I think it
raises not just methodological and
biological questions but rillette achill
questions if you want to improve
certains because what would potentially
they be the downside of it so what about
memory and memory something you know to
varying degrees we're all here slowly
moving along chronologically and
everybody worries about what's going to
happen to your memory and you know in my
world people have the ability to
sometimes put electrodes into the brain
that allows us to stimulate the brain
and there's a number of reports of
different parts of the brain if you
stimulate it just the right way you can
make somebody some of these memory
performance better and how do you think
of that it's not a way to combat you
know combat aging per se but to help
people adjust as they get older and
keeping memory intact forget about super
memory even just trying to keep memory
intact as we go along how do you see us
approaching that I mean correct me if
I'm wrong but aren't there less sexy
innovative ways that people think about
or have studied to enhance some of these
processes so for example the things that
we know we should do like getting good
sleep exercising engaging and cognitive
stimulation throughout a lifetime have
been associated with better cognitive
aging in the long run so those are hard
things that we all know we should do but
routine things that we should be doing
that
may actually be improving some of this
retention over the long term so
lifestyle modifications to work and and
do work through plasticity the physical
exercise promotes cognitive function I
mean that and in fact if you do an
analysis of all the studies that have
done been done in the literature which
we just did just published em there is a
I don't know why this is the number but
there is about 52 hours a day 52 hours
talked about enhancing 50 tours in six
months actually so it's not not a lot
and and and it doesn't matter how many
hours per day you do is sort of a total
amount of dose almost say so but but you
need to put in some hours but it's not a
ton of hours of physical exercise that
improves cognitive function in the
elderly so so I think that there is an
effect of physical exercise on to the
brain and it appears to be linked to
mechanisms of plasticity in that lisa's
as one can prove them in humans with
brain imaging and brain stimulation
techniques but but i think rather than
getting at the level of suggestions you
should sleep better you know avoid
medications that are bad for you eat the
right thing and the right amount and you
know exercise and challenge your brain
with new things and have social
relationships all those things are true
and but but we should be able to get to
enough understanding that we can
prescribe it that we can tell then this
is the number of hours of this exercise
that you need to do and here's how we're
going to help you actually convert this
this hopes into realities right because
it's hard to stick with a program like
that so I think that stay that's the
step that we still don't have is the
understanding of how to actually make
this a prescribed herbal intervention
like we do with medications we don't
tell patients take something for that
you know
we tell them what to take and
mods and so forth and so I think we need
that level of understanding but what
about new happiness set points right
everybody wants wellness everybody so is
it possible that we're gonna someday
understand the brain well enough to say
oK you've been through a really terrible
life trauma but we can actually help
your set point well I think you know I
would think about sort of maybe not
happiness but that feeling of being able
to regulate your emotions to be able to
feel less sad when you want to be able
to feel more sad when you want to kind
of have that emotion regulation ability
and so there are studies for example
with people who meditate which we
generally think of as a healthy
lifestyle practice but there are
different levels of expertise and
meditation right so there are Buddhist
monks who do this for say 40,000 hours
in total versus really really dedicated
meditators who might have done this for
20,000 hours and then novices and this
research has shown that the amount of
meditation practice practice being the
key word that the behavior has to be
routinely engaged with is associated
with brain changes in the regions of the
brain like the prefrontal cortex that we
know are associated with emotion
regulation what's interesting in that
finding and it relates back to the
original walking example and the quote
about habit is that it there was this
inverted u-shaped dose response function
such that the individuals who were
meditating a lot but not to the degree
of the Buddhist monks actually had the
most different prefrontal cortex
activity and then it came back down
again for the Buddhist monks suggesting
that there
is this element of plasticity in the
brain regions that we think are that we
know are associated with emotion
regulation but an element of habit can
come into play as well so that it starts
to become more of a naturally occurring
state of the brain that can be as you
were referring to before kind of the
core process that's being affected
rather than the more superficial so I
would have to say in in summary that
obviously we have a really really tight
balance between plasticity stability but
as we've all learned they're incredibly
exciting things not just normal behavior
attacking diseases going down the road
and but in the meantime eat well sleep
well
meditate once in a while exercise a
whole lot and surround yourself with
really smart people who make you happy
for that I thank all of you
[Music]
you
[Music]